[Music]
from the past news yeah Saved by the
Bell diner is coming to Los Angeles I'm
sorry
what is the looking at you like why do
you actually know the lingo when I pick
up but uh set a book and I think I like
the look can I go though and I said it's
alright cuz it's the same on a baby I
made a lot of never sell
I've never seen it I was watching you
young soccer [ __ ] did you guys watch
black and white what the [ __ ] is that
it was unlike UPN 13 as mutters black
dude and a white dude they're just like
chillin know what's called black and
white how many seasons ago I don't know
I think more than one year I never liked
watching channel 13 what I think there
was just nothing on there like it's all
different channels - I watched channel 5
channel 13 and channel 11 maybe wasn't
black and white but it was the way I
kind of like it doesn't even exist
another show called black and white but
it's not the one he's talking about no I
think that would probably just a black
and a white guy you're like hey I'm
watching black and white you know I'm
proud to be nobody
okay I like this thank you oh they watch
that one it's the black version of Sex
and the City
now yeah sister sells Queen Latifah no
[Laughter]
living single yeah living single like
that's him that's a Sex in the City but
the black people version right yeah
remember Moesha Moesha Brandon molted
the maureesa you can tell who raised us
growing up not our [ __ ] Harry
television man man mr. Cooper man oh
yeah
hey don't forget about family matters
but that's the recognition when you read
in the good news on the newspaper page
love a tradition I'm so amazed you guys
it's all the power dreams room right now
there's this pop-up diner
that's popped up in Chicago last year
folks Chicago why not always welcome
living it to LA okay fine starting with
the beginning of the story so then it
was in Chicago first it was only
supposed to be there for a month but
they ended up running it for a whole
year
I'm a cute we're in LA that's the thing
and is it just art exhibit or I really
saw himself or a separate of food
[Laughter]
[Music]
I forgot anyone remember the diner here
what it was a sigh that's it oh that's
the college waters high school the
restaurant was called very caboose the
math do Kelly Kapowski would give me he
thought Jesse Jesse
I like Jesse that's why you problem with
us gypsies huh oh she was the
curly-haired [ __ ] right yeah that's why
you're AC Slater and you like Jesse's
fat yeah and I'm taller than you you
know she was pretty but Kelly Kapowski
her eyes I was like oh but she was
beautiful
least someone's good - she always made
me feel happy for the fact that I'm
building Tiffany I'm beautiful
my name's Tiffany do we have that
connection
how many ways so this is what the menu
looks like oh the max yeah and then they
have like this week I want to work there
alright the quit your job yeah so that's
what it look like in Chicago so they're
saying the LA one should probably look
about the same better [ __ ] I'm gonna be
pissed
I walk in there this is not Saved by the
Bell who the [ __ ] did this [ __ ] oh I
want Kelly Kapowski to be there dude
[ __ ] she's still pretty though she's
still pretty alright come on no man she
looks like a soccer mom now really I
said what is this part like 50 years old
now Jennifer Aniston JLo
Jayla okay but jell-o's different dude
she kills babies and uses their skin on
her so she looks [ __ ] how about how
about what she look like right now cuz I
feel like she looks old
you know why I fell into those stupid
cites words like celebrities then and
now and then you just keep cooking and
clicking and clicking they show the
worst photos of them no like right when
they wake up with you
everybody looks terrible right wake up I
had a crush on Jessie Jessie Spano she
was a striptease Belle God - she was a
baby and then she still looks amazing
like if you were if that was a thumbnail
- a porno you wouldn't click that come
on Jessie whether one is Jessie look
like now busting his buck
you know why because celebrities have
money always better now money is like
for some reason you just don't age
it's just that better lifestyle yeah
better water coming through your shower
yes you get to use a steam room now and
then people are massaging you every day
yeah you eat clean food mm-hmm I don't
care how hot she doesn't look like a
[ __ ] grandpa by the time I'm 33 no
she doesn't
Tiffany I think so too Mitchell would
you click on a portal set dries bug that
way that way better I'd rather learn how
to freaking fold my sheets and not jack
off to the other one it's cuz she's
wearing what she's wearing I care more
no doesn't that picture she looks like a
porn star there no I'm talking about in
the she did but she liked her more ever
since growing up always - yeah she just
looks like she's ready to [ __ ]
I liked her in showgirls oh yeah her
shop rose to almost every show I always
liked the one that wasn't the main one
like growing up but not on Juno or
whatever I always like the other girl mm
I never thought they were she doesn't
look insane though like she looks like
more real natural yeah shows more
naturally it only looks like she got she
looks awesome though for someone that's
like 500 she does look pretty good she
looks like she bathed in the Sun a
little too long though just a little she
got Botox like even what uh with
Destiny's Child I always like Kelly
Rowland more than Beyonce but what tell
you I like Kelly Rowland better too
though but Kelly was [ __ ] hot as hell
though I don't know about now but back
then I think beyoncé and Kelly Rowland
are two different types of hot but I
think they're hot is on the same level
in my personal opinion general best food
job did she yeah I had no idea I like
mr. Elliot
say you like Rosie O'Donnell you guys
don't know I always go for the girl that
no guys would go for it could she do
anything yep so go for screech yep go
for screech screech was a poor start
what yeah Dustin Diamond yeah yeah that
he has a dick molded out of his oh he
does a dildo molded from his dick yeah
like a bee took a cast mold and they
made a dildo and they sell it
why does a big ass [ __ ] dig with a
fro around it but it was like a huge
thing huge he went into porn and [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] did you rebrand it himself yeah
bang looking you were like on the Howard
Stern Show or whatever I don't know if I
can taint my dick like that all porn cuz
it's gonna be so boring it just [ __ ]
afterwards oh like bringing your work
home mm-hmm
I can't do that you can imagine like how
hard this actually do porn I know you
know cuz I mean technically on the like
a shoot day you'd be like doing it for
eight hours straight yeah home run off
you can't get there you know it's like
kind of like torture at some point
wouldn't you think mother I know cuz I
can't stay awake after I know I'm trying
to go to sleep until the house is on
fire
nope too late you already made me not
hey guys would you think of that video I
know you loved it so make sure to hit
that like button to watch more videos
check it out up here
[Music]